welcome to the five the white house
wrapping up a press briefing just now
dr fauci making a lot of news by what he
said about the trump administration
fauci saying he feels liberated also
adding this
one of the things that we're going to do
is to be completely transparent
open and honest if things go wrong
not point fingers but to correct them
and to make everything we do
be based on science and evidence
dr fauci also pushing back on a cnn
report
that the biden administration was left a
mess
on the vaccine we'll have that sound
administration
starting from scratch with the vaccine
distribution effort
or are you picking up where the trump
administration left off
no i mean um we certainly are not
starting from scratch because there is
activity going on in the distribution
all right so greg obviously that cnn
report that the biden team was starting
from scratch on vaccine distribution
was fake news so that's the first fake
news story we've seen
you want to mark that down right yes day
two and uh and
also what did you think about dr fauci
right there and his comments about the
differences between the two
administrations well okay
when you notice something about uh about
him is that he's kind of a political
animal
have you ever worked in a company uh
under someone and there's a change this
is normal
he's one of those co-workers that plays
the field politically and will always
end up being on the side of who's ever
in charge
which is why he kind of spewed these
talking points at the start that
seemed contradictory to what actually
happened we saw the briefings
we saw i don't think you could get any
more transparent than those briefings
trump said whatever was on his mind he
often
quibbled with with uh fauci um there was
no
nothing fauci said as advice was ever
ignored by trump in fact i think trump
was ahead of fouchy
when he came to the uh travel ban on
china and he was on board with a
shutdown the moment that it happened and
and he was willing to sacrifice his
entire successful and effective
achievements
with an economy uh to with the shutdown
uh if you if you listen to the press you
would have thought that trump wouldn't
have done that
i also want to point out that that
presser man every question is about
trump it's
i think for the media trump's like an
old flame who really really burned you
bad
so much so it's like you just can't let
him go and i bet
i bet a hundred bucks jesse
people in the white house press briefing
room are gonna be drunk dialing trump
late at night when they're alone just to
hear his voice we've all been there by
the way
and he and he might pick up the phone
uh yeah personally
um the way i feel if you work for an
organization whether it's
an administration or a company and
you're expected to not
toe the line but you're expected to
present
kind of a a united front fauci did not
do that
he has never done that and i i honestly
agree with greg he seems very political
like he pivoted
really fast right when those
administrations change and now people
kind of have whiplash
and are kind of seeing the real fouchy i
think well i think
if you went back jesse there were many
times on this program where we would
point to the fact that dr fauci defended
president trump
and said that doctor that president
trump was very engaged in operation warp
speed and with the task force
he defended president trump and saying
he listens to me that there's
don't you remember when dr fauci said
there is nothing we have brought to the
president that he hasn't listened to and
that he hasn't acted on
so i in some ways i think that you know
it's
we shouldn't forget that um but yes of
course
he's he has a job that he wants to
continue
and the thing is is that the press knows
that one of the best things to do to get
headlines and
clicks and attention is to ask about
a previous boss it always happens now
if i were dr fauci i might have said
looking forward here
i'm not going to look backwards like he
he said that but then he went
a step further and said but let's be
clear like it was obvious that uh we
were out of favor
and i think one of the things that if
you look back to march the president's
approval ratings really went up do you
remember when he
had the task force there he was
deferring to the doctors he was
listening to them
and and they helped him for a while and
then that all
sort of fell apart for many different
reasons including ones where he got
frustrated especially about
the shutdowns and the lockdowns and some
of that advice the conflicting advice
the other thing that i saw today is dr
fauci defending the trump administration
and saying
there absolutely was a vaccine
distribution but it wasn't just dr fauci
dr redfield of the cdc also said that so
there are um there there's a lot that
the country has gone through when it
comes to covid uh dr fauci does have
um some a popularity rating that's
pretty high in america's people
tend to listen to him want to trust him
i think that he was actually
um trying to be gracious uh as much as
he possibly could while also being
completely honest
um so i i guess that's where it's a
tough balancing act there
and sometimes it is believe me
yes we all have been there and we have
some more sound from dr fauci we'll play
it and juan can react to that
it was very clear that there were things
that were said uh be it
regarding things like hydroxychloroquine
and other things like that
that really was an uncomfortable because
they were not based on scientific fact
i can tell you i i take no pleasure at
all
in being in a situation of contradicting
the president so it was really something
that you didn't feel that you could
actually say something and there
wouldn't be any repercussions about it
the idea
that you can get up here and talk about
what you know
what the evidence what the science is
and know that's it
let the science speak it is somewhat of
a liberating feeling
oh juan aren't we so glad that dr
anthony fauci
feels liberated inside from what i
remember i mean he
spoke a lot during the trump
administration he was on every tv show
for months
i think you uh forget that for a long
time he wasn't even allowed i mean he
was doing podcasts there he had been
excommunicated told to go to his
corner uh not invited to there's some
very popular podcasts
okay i'm just telling you he wasn't
allowed on the ear you said you saw but
anyway
my point to you is i think it's pretty
clear that he's saying
he is much more comfortable hearing from
president biden that the science and the
evidence
will carry the day and you know i think
he was a good employee he was a good
scientist remember he works for the
national institutes of health and he
wanted
he wanted to help president trump and he
wanted to have
president trump's ear i think dr burks
also was someone later excommunicated
who felt
it's best to have a presence with the
president of the united states during
a health crisis now obviously the
president subsequently brought in
other doctors let me just leave it there
but he brought in people who were just
telling him what he wanted to hear is
what it looked like
and berks and fauci then got the boot
and so today to hear him to hear him say
you know science
and evidence will carry the day i think
he's just speaking the truth to you
all right dagon give you the last word
uh what we said
we saw in how dr fauci was treated by
the press how well maybe every member of
the biden administration
will be treated because he got the the
go-to question
how do you feel it's the figurative
neck rub and the foot massage
that he gets in public and by the way
can we just point out
dr fauci is not infallible he went on 60
minutes in front of the american people
in early march and told him don't bother
wearing a mask
when all of asia for literally years had
been wearing a mask
of course the cdc changed its guidance
but let's stop acting like this guy has
gotten it right all along
trump got it right pushing the vaccine
and i'll also note that
president biden got very testy earlier
in the afternoon when asked about if a
hundred million
vaccinations in a hundred days was
enough
and he said when i announced it you all
said it wasn't possible well
nobody said that in the press everybody
just shook their head yeah
you're right you're right he said come
on give me a break man
it's a good start so he's getting a
little testy getting a little
thin-skinned if it was trump he'd be
called
well a lunatic but that's bud
so we got our first come on man and we
got our first cnn fake news story
we're off to a good start everybody